>> CHRIS GALLAER,HANK YOU SO
MUCH.
PEOPLE DON' INKR TALK
O MUCH ABOUT ARCHITECRE
DESIGNED OR EV THEIR TOWNS A
SIGN,BUT THEREIS A REASON
THAT THIN ARBUILT THE WAY
TH ARE.
THEY AR EIER P- HUMAN OR
ANTIHUN.
UNFORTATEL, SOUCH  OUR
ARITECTURE AND SI CITY
PLNING IS ANTIMAN IDE ONE
OF THE VY FE PLANNE THAT
PLAN ARCHICTURE IN A W THAT
BRINGS PEOPLTOGEER AND MAKES
THEMAPPY
THE CONGRESS FOR THE NEWURBANIS
CIES WHERE PEOPLMIGHT
ACTULY KNOW EACHOTHEONCE
AGN.
WE HAVAN AZING CONVERSAON.
HERE IS PART  IT.
>> THE WN PLAN REAY
AFFE YOUR LIFE.
FOR AMPL A KID THAT HAS TO
BEDRIV EVERHERE ASA KI
WI NO EEDOM AT ALL.
PERN THATCAN  LOER
DRIV AS APRISONER.
SOHEN WE DESIGNRE PCES
THAT ARE ABE ALL WALKABLWHERE Y
LKING, YOU CANHAVEA CAR,UT
YOU DOT HAVE TO USE
ANDI THK WHAT MAKES ERICA
MANDATORY. THAT E CAIS
YOU DID NOT HAVE A CAR ALMO
TO THENDIVUAL LEVEL,
INVIDU WITH A CAR, U WOULD
ARVE TO DEATHN COUPLE OF DAYS.
>> W ARE SO USED TO AT, THAT
WE DON'T AGINOURSELVES50
TIL ABOUT 1950 BEFORE THE CARS
WERE WIDESPRD, BORE
EVERYTHING ESSTIAL HAVE ONE,
EVERY ACERIGHTCROS
CUURES, YOU NEED YO DAILY
MEATS WITH WALKING DISTCE.
ITAS NORMAL.
THE ROMANSID COME AT TH
CHINESE DIIT, EVERYONE